that's an area that i've been diving
into myself which is childhood trauma
attachment trauma yeah and
everyone has it yeah everybody yeah
yeah you're able to
identify something in that yeah i so in
2016 i remembered
being abused as a child
and
i remembered it through a dream first
and then i was like no thank you i'm not
gonna touch that because it's terrifying
that was just a bad dream that was no
but it was a real dream like you know
when you were i woke up and i was like
that was the most real dream i've ever
had
then i uh wound up a days later just
down the street from here in my
therapist office and she said something
that triggered me to accept that it was
true and that put me on a really deep
journey of big big growth and recovery
so part of my story is because i was so
overwhelmed by anxiety and stress that
was too much for me as a child and i
didn't have the caregivers in place to
help me so when when you have a child
big feelings are happening so a parent
or caregiver has to help that child
understand what's happening and learn to
navigate their emotions yeah so without
that in absence of that
because i was so overwhelmed the gift of
our our mind is that it will never let
us be overwhelmed yeah find a way to
cope but what i what i realized when
when it all happened was
for about a year or two leading up there
were so many moments where i had
actually said to him you know i actually
don't really want to be in this and
i had this naive idea that he needed me
because i was sort of in this caretaker
role in our relationship and i i think
my ego was just way ahead of itself
thinking like i'm needed here and this
is very codependent dynamic
and so
um at one point i actually wished
i remember he went away and i was laying
in bed and i was looking at the ceiling
and i was like oh i hope he just falls
in love with somebody else so that they
can take care of him and i won't have to
feel bad for breaking up with him and
then he ended up he did he within a
month or two of that he wow he
ended up
in love with somebody else and he left
and the interesting thing was is that
this person who i didn't even want to be
with all of a sudden i was just
desperate for him oh why do you why do
you think that happened well the
abandonment wound was so alive in that
moment and that's the thing is the
abandonment wound is what keeps us going
back to these toxic relationships or
just relationships that don't serve us
or
people who really aren't in alignment
for us because that part of us that is
so afraid to be abandoned again just
gets activated when someone rejects us
or leaves even if they're not right
saying how you know you're just
introverted and shy and uncomfortable in
a room
have you ever figured out
where that comes from
you know i think it everything sort of
comes from your childhood
um i had a
you know
from the outside looking in
and if i really you know if i really
think about it i had a very good
i had a lot of great breaks as a child
and a teenager and had a lot of
opportunity
um
i really did i i
i'm not going to complain one bit about
the position or the situation but it
wasn't always perfect my parents got
divorced in 78
i lived with my mom
never saw dad i've got like one or two
kind of memories of dad before i was
probably sixer or so
i don't really know how much he was
around or how often we were able we were
sent to be with him you know like if he
got visitations i don't know when he got
him or how often he got him or how often
he took his opportunity to do that
i don't have a lot of memory of that
and
i was living with mom
in a time in a real small house in
kannapolis and woke up one morning the
house was on fire
and
big time on fire and so
i
mom's boyfriend comes into the bedroom
and he's like hey get on get your pjs on
we got to get out of here and i'm like
uh
i'm
just kind of waking up and i'm like i
don't know what's going on but i get my
pj's on and i walk out of my bedroom and
i look to the right and the whole
kitchen is just a big wall of fire
craziest thing i've ever seen in my life
i mean you know you
you never forget some things like that
but we walk outside and the next thing i
know i'm standing you know day or two
later i'm standing in dad's garage at
lake norman in mooresville and all our
stuff's in there all our stuff's in the
garage and
we're gonna live with dad my whole
childhood was discomfort my whole
childhood was um
[Music]
i i shouldn't i guess i shouldn't say
whole because there were
beautiful parts of it you know i have um
like i said my relationship with my
grandparents i have really beautiful
memories of my childhood but um
i i truly believe that my parents did
the best that they could with what they
had
but their best
was not
great and um
my
i grew up inside of chaos i grew up
inside of fear i grew up um
daddy had a
awful temper and you never knew you know
what was going to happen you never knew
are we going to have a nice family
dinner or
um
is he going to get angry and they're
going to get a fight he's going to punch
a hole in the wall or through you know
rip the tv and throw it back like you
just you never knew and so um i lived i
can i've done a lot of therapy to
understand sort of the effect that that
has on
a child and growing up in this anxiety
of
a i don't i never feel safe so like as a
child i never feel safe because i never
know what to expect
and also um
my role then was
to keep the peace
like try and make everybody happy try
and uh you know oh no no like let's make
it a joke let's you know we'll just
laugh this off it's fine like oh she
didn't mean that like he you know so
there's a lot of stuff
um from the time
i was little that
you know i've written a lot about it in
my books and
there is a whole
bucket of [ __ ] that i will never write
about because it's
too awful
oh i can handle
crap i can handle being treated like
[ __ ] i can handle all the whatever
emotional abuse or anything that's gone
on
um
is to imagine
the way that someone's treating me would
i ever let them treat my little girl
like that yeah and i imagine that to be
my inner child yes and so i somewhat
disassociate from it even though i know
it's me yes it's easier to access the
ability to treat myself properly if i
imagine that it's a little girl in me
and you know if you dissociate from a
trauma it's on lockdown but your body
still remembers you get triggered all
the time you you just you know you
become you can become an addict you can
become a workaholic you can do all the
things to avoid the feelings of those
triggers but when you start to practice
something like emdr therapy it starts to
open up the brain to start to like
my therapist said it in this way where
it opens up the resourced part of your
brain that can help you
almost
work out the traumatic experience in
that moment
so at the time
the adaptation that i made was to do
what is called dissociating which is
detaching which is i call it my
spaceship i used to go away in
and it was as if and on the outside you
would never know i would appear here i
could have a full conversation with you
but in terms of attachment to my body i
wasn't in my body i wasn't connected i
couldn't tell you how my body even like
physiologically felt let alone the
emotions sure that i was having but i
could navigate the situation and that
was a form of protection so i was up on
my spaceship hovering safely above
the things that were too difficult for
me to feel you removed
every last bit of yourself
other than the one that just was there
whatever the power down and i got this
is where i got really good this is where
this codependency started
at showing up the way you needed me to
in a conventional relationship
if you do something to hurt me
my first instinct is to react to blame
you to demonize you
and to put all of the blame on you
and and then to do whatever my coping
mechanism is sure so okay so that could
be trying to convince you to love me
deeper because i have this wound in me
that needs validation it could be to
ghost you because you know once you've
hurt me you're out
um whatever that coping mechanism is
that's where i would deploy it and and i
would continue on the pattern now in a
conscious relationship the only thing
that makes it really different is that
when you hurt me
i'm able to sit with that and share what
hurt me and set a boundary if needed
and also look within myself
and ask questions like what does this
represent for me right now what does
this feeling remind me of is there a
time when i was little where i remember
feeling this way
and and then i can go deeper and like
what is the fear underneath that and
then how can i share my need in a way
that you can now meet me so instead of
pushing love away i'm learning how to
work with what's coming up in me as a
way to bring me closer to you in
relationship and then also for some of
us who like to use spiritual language
you know closer to god or to source or
to higher power whatever
and that's really it it's can we slow
down enough to be self-aware in each
moment and take some responsibility
that's it
so do you have to recognize the trauma
not even you don't even have to remember
anything you can just talk about the way
it physically feels or you could talk
about how you yelled at the doorman
today and that experience of yelling at
the doorman might have been your trauma
response and so if you just go into the
feeling of that trauma response it can
unlock the the fight or flight
we think the thoughts that we rehearse
are we tended we're so habitual we're
habitual in our behaviors yeah we're
habitual in our thoughts if you start to
tune in and be conscious and observe
your thoughts
most of us will see that they're very i
call them narratives because they're
repetitive they're the same story yeah
whether it's the story i'm telling me
about myself
about my relationships my place in the
world other people
story story stories and we think we're
the feelings that we're used to having
but if we look back at the development
of all of this we are we are that
awareness that's what we will remain
however over time
right we've stored all of this other
crap all of the our habits have been
stored that's what we were taught we
were taught that's how you take care of
your body or that's what you do in the
morning or that's not what you do in the
morning we've been rehearsing thoughts
for so long that now their beliefs
that's who we think we are we have a
story essentially that lives in our mind
that that's who we think we are and i am
now a liver of the experience of that's
not who we are we are the awareness and
while those are conditioned i used to
work conditioning a lot those are
conditioned patterns
we can uncondition ourselves and we can
give ourselves freedom to make new
choices so when i started to practice at
dale this is where the family stuff
really started to get involved in my
healing as i started to observe myself
and watch
the thoughts i was having when i'm
around my family thoughts about my
family in general thoughts that were
coloring my other relationships that
were connected to my family as i started
to observe how i felt around my family
and other people that i was relating to
how do you feel when you're when you're
going to hang out with this person how
do you feel when you're hanging out with
these people how do you feel when you
leave these people so mom
was broke and had to move back to
norfolk virginia to be uh
closer to some family there
that was the decision she made she
couldn't afford
uh
it was just going to be too hard on her
to contain uh to maintain me and kelly
and and she had no job or nothing at
that time
and so we went to live with dad i didn't
know dad i didn't know teresa she was
there and part of dad's life at that
point
um
and that was a hard thing me and theresa
when i was a kid man we butt heads hard
um
you know we were sprung into her life
she wasn't
you know she was with dad and thinking
man i've got this vision of the future
and here comes these two kids from his
previous marriage
that are just now okay gonna you know
we're gonna just plop into the household
and she's gotta adjust her expectations
of her future with dad i understand her
frustration with that
um
but me and kelly you know kelly and me
we just tried you know it was weird
there was a lot of good
amazing things that happened because now
i'm with dad i get to get to know him
get to go to the races it was an
amazing experience to be going to
racetracks and enjoying all those things
but
um
and then when you go to school so we'd
go to school and you would think that
man you know your dad's dale earnhardt
and everybody's gonna go wow that's cool
you're you're cool because your dad's
cool but it wasn't like that you know it
just people
are the kids i was going to school with
uh didn't
think it was cool you know and
that didn't create advantages for me
like you might think
uh and i was a uh
i was
uh i had like two or three four friends
you know in in school
um i knew a lot of people i mean you
know just trying to think back on my
my high school days i just
was it
i don't know i wasn't outgoing and and
wasn't one to strike up a conversation
and i was real real quiet and i think it
just kind of
created this sort of uh
this this sort of sustained
um personality and and approach to life
um
all through you know my teenage years we
went to a lot of different schools i
ended up getting sent to military school
for a couple years i was in a christian
school
got in big trouble there
talking talking in class and just doing
stupid stuff you know being in being a
clown
um
man when i went to christian school i
did kind of come out of my shell for a
minute i was only there for half a year
for whatever reason
the other kids in that school were like
me
the day my brother died is the last day
my parents ever parented me
and i was 14.
and
that and i mean
legitimately they checked out
and
from 14 until i graduated like nobody
one time
you know did you brush your teeth did
you do your homework what are your
grades
never how um
no and and what i say in the book is
i've had more conversations with my 11
year old about fortnight
than either one of my parents have ever
had with me
about my brother's death
you know what i saw that day what i went
through the trauma of that experience
nothing so look at the words you use
like i can handle the emotional abuse
and whatever it is like yeah and people
might describe you it's like oh no she's
awesome she's tough would probably be a
word and you look at your career
and the fact that you're competing
against guys and in a sport that is love
you know all of the things right like
that speaks to somebody whose persona
has become you know very robust
but that doesn't speak to what's beneath
it
when you recognize that you have
feelings right and i'm not talking in a
woo-woo kind of kumbaya but you're a
sentient being you're a woman you know
an extraordinary woman and an
accomplished woman and a caring woman
and the degree to which all of that gets
kind of pushed to one side because you
can handle the abuse as i tell people
just because it's familiar doesn't mean
it's healthy right
totally yeah so so can you just even if
it's a word or two if you recognize the
degree to which you've discarded some of
your own
like
care of self
what would that leave you feeling like
it's an unconscious process it's the
blue tinted glasses you didn't know so
you don't have to feel shame or guilt
but once you see it and go wow i've
really disregarded my needs over and
over and over
like how does that hit you when you
really see it
like negligent like
abusive in the opposite way that i
express it yeah right it's avoidant yeah
it's disassociative yeah even though i
express more on the side of codependency
or or the anxious attachment or the
wanting or diving in or
unpacking talking
it's actually
inside of myself it feels like it is
the opposite side of the spectrum which
is the same hole as we've kind of been
expressing and it would be like i've
disassociated with myself and so it
feels um
that's why it's so hurtful because
that's exactly what i do to myself there
you go so a there's now you've used a
word that i want which is it's hurtful
because all the words you're super
articulate but they're all they're a
little bit still from here up right and
i'm just wanting to get a little bit
closer to this thing which you have a
huge one on
but really that's the first glimpse
you've given me it's hurtful
like as much as you can say i can handle
the emotional abuse of whatever
boyfriend this or
male dad or it doesn't even have to be
male but you get the point i'm sure if i
wear a fly on the wall of your life i
would have witnessed a lot that is
hurtful
but you've learned to protect yourself
and be okay with it even though you're
not actually okay with it energetically
and physiologically it will manifest in
different ways over time you know you're
still young and healthy but over time
that's what becomes dis-ease
you know manifest physiologically
because of the absence of ease in our
system because we're actually hurt and
hurts bedfellow is also fear scared yeah
so that little girl who's protected
herself by virtue of becoming tough and
resilient is actually hurt and scared
she's hurt from a past event that was
tough and now she's scared of its
repetition
now that's a different breath right so
there's something energetically that
just got released
so that i'm guessing is going to be part
of your experiences that at times that
little girl who i guarantee you is a
sweetheart very shy very creative very
sensitive but felt the experience of not
being wanted is my guess
i mean just in recent experiences of
like things that have gone on and oh no
i'm going to cry onto you yeah it's
beautiful but it was like it's okay this
is beautiful
like i realized that this is the world